tras días de mucha presión de críticas
en su contra el gobierno alemán confirmó
este miércoles que autoriza el envío
tanto de manera directa como a través de
terceros países de los tanques de
fabricación alemana leopard a Ucrania en
una declaración ante el parlamento
alemán el mundo está el canciller olace
distanció de las críticas que ha
recibido en su contra críticas que lo
ven como un líder que se demora
demasiado en tomar decisiones y enfatizó
por el contrario la importancia que pone
su gobierno en discutir el envío de
estos tanques con los aliados más
cercanos en particular con Estados
Unidos en evitar decisiones unilaterales
que puedan tener efectos indeseados
todavía no se conocen todos los detalles
prácticos y logísticos del envío de
estos tanques pero sí se ha asegurado
que se espera que el entrenamiento de
los soldados ucranianos empiece muy
pronto aquí en Alemania y no solamente
en el uso de los tanques sino también en
todos los temas de mantenimiento y
reparación y se ha hablado en los medios
alemanes de un posible envío hasta
finales de marzo asegurando que el
entrenamiento puede durar entre 6 y 8
semanas De cualquier manera la decisión
de este miércoles es clave para el
gobierno alemán que espera así disminuir
las críticas en su contra y volver a
poner el énfasis en el rol que juega
ayudando a Ucrania en esta guerra no
solamente en temas políticos y
económicos sino también en asuntos
militares